hey guys Ryan right here and tonight I'm
gonna be watching the trailer for Tom
Cruise's new movie edge of darkness I
really want to watch this movie you get
a car and you get a cup it's a third
trailer this film looks awesome
you know like first trailer was like
this kind of looks like a Tom Cruise
movie but cool second travels like this
do me one hell of a sci-fi flick I'm
ready to watch this trailer not much
where he could say than the fact that it
looks sweet and Tom turd is super
intense still has a great body looking
kind of saggy lately but whatever Warner
Bros can tell you sounds crazy very
lives depend on what days it for you
Judgment Day you just came in with the
fresh recruits oh [ __ ]
Wow look at that shot new day people
destiny calm I'm choking on these before
Hey so intense I love it
but shaky perspective
come find me when you wake up Sunday
people
you didn't tomorrow at the beach we are
fighting a Lincoln isn't it funny how
she was also awarded how to reset the
day and also to you
many people
I don't control
every guy
I'm not even trained for combat this
movie is gonna be [ __ ] sweet
your legs broken no okay so can I go
show them it's like 50 first dates into
Groundhog Day meets oblivious I'm so
tired
you're a weapon every time you die you
get smarter
oh whoa I didn't know you what I do I
know get the reclaim this every time how
does he make progress
yeah
dude my Tom Cruise kicked so much ass
how many times have we been here how
many times he gets better at sex every
time
for me it's been an eternity
are you max I wouldn't how many times
you're gonna see that shot at him waking
up
it's got text my mom saying I got a
parking ticket and then expired tags I
got a ticket for that too
now the tags I understand what the
parking ticket that's karma man I bet
someone do what I did to someone once
one time I was walking by a car and
there's a parking ticket on it and I
just took the parking ticket I used to
be a pretty big [ __ ] but a lot can
change in one week by the Gil and he
will let me take his virginity ah no
wait how old are you it might be okay
message me if you're under 18 don't
message me 18 and over message me for
your girl message me if you're a guy
don't message me actually message me
still I feel flattered Achmed booked
karf vada
he said I was awesome you don't need to
tell me something I already know
Achmed booked Hufford Arta what are you
like the third brother that wasn't
featured in The Lion King Mufasa scar
Achmed bukhara Dom no kidney out that's
not your real name
wait no if it is cool but I said I hope
it's not a real name in terms of I don't
want to insult you but yeah dude thanks
for saying I'm awesome
it makes me feel good to know that you
think I'm awesome I could use more
compliments especially after my mom
played me go Tyrone Hamilton dude wanted
to shout out Tyrone I've only met black
guys the entire roan and they're all
cool man one of the worst thing if
you're black good for you because one of
the worst things what time I went to a
urinal and on one side of me was a black
guy and on the other side of me was
another black guy it just felt like I
had the smallest penis in the world did
I take a gander yeah I did and my penis
was definitely the smallest one and I
have a very medium-sized penis AOA
Tyrone thanks for wanting a shout out
cool man
you can have a shout-out I'm gonna work
out my dick Tyrone can you message me a
picture of your penis